how's it going brace it house cumbrous
beautiful Jesus Christ what is this
welcome to Pizza land now I know you're
thinking oh another shitty you need a
game no this game is made in 2002 I
agree
I just I'm speechless alright I'm
walking I'm walking I what is this a
reward a lot of euro for getting them
the angry red face got it what am I
don't want to know don't want to know
let's cross the bridge to pizza lined
I'm stuck I'm [ __ ] stuck forever
where did you get that outfit it looks
[ __ ] great I think I just found my my
next Halloween costume into the dark we
go this is actually terrifying I pay
money for this if I can paid money for
this game I are we go what is this what
I do it what you calling what am i doing
you're just making noise this game stop
I can't even figure out the first puzzle
damn it okay I open the gut bed let's
pizzeria this at the way yeah all right
let's go it's so happy I'm like a slug
duck worm okay wallet stripe the car no
what the [ __ ] did I do the [ __ ] did I do
well but stop teleporting it must be
annoying to always hold out my arms
maybe then in our arms maybe they are
eels
alright the [ __ ] it I don't know let's
go here okay sure sure
alright cool I think pet Oh God is that
it
what is that a demon it's not a demon
it's a chicken what's the [ __ ]
chicken hey chicken let's go this way
whoa whoa there's graphics Brett is
there walkthrough of this game has
anyone ever actually played this game
maybe I need to catch the chicken come
here chicken
check out command check out my chicken
chicken out in public chicken Oh God
alright you know why continue oh I can
change angle where why didn't you say so
all I wanted to do was to enter Pedro's
pizzeria
but I chant alright three hours later I
finally figured out how to play this
game I think so I can run yes I can run
[ __ ] amazing Oh what the [ __ ] is this
I didn't even know I could go here oh
[ __ ] that's cool I have to wait here
puzzles how do they work are you having
fun yet what the [ __ ] is that what the
[ __ ] is everything in this game this
game predicted Illuminati before
Illuminati pizza man
Oh fighter of Pedras pizza [ __ ] I don't
know oh alright more nightmares what
else can this game offer this is where
nightmares come from there was no
nightmares prior to this game can I go
in Pedras pizza now No
I read the card whoa whoa this is the
greatest game ever oh my god this
changes everything everything ribbit is
that the gas cloud is that the [ __ ]
gas cloud nothing I'll ever play after
this game we'll live up to this let's
just scatter some strength
add some epic music for Sweden
goddammit Mott yes ah ah what do I do
now I'm here dammit I didn't think this
through
Oh oh okay all right
that's I'm a I'm a [ __ ] bird I'm a
pizza delivery [ __ ] bird I'm
walking on sunshine Hey now we can go to
the castle is that the story is that
what we wanted Fame and richness alright
he's my father
did he fart she's [ __ ] fart they
didn't pay this was a horror game I
imagine this is what drugs feels like
this has been a joyful ride and
experience a really really breathtaking
and life-changing experience I'm glad I
got to experience this with you brothers
leave a like means you're watching
subscriber Cumbre today and i will see
you in the next one stay awesome bros i
spooky so skin
well it my W yes thousand